um
and we just said this that uh one
drawback of a ridge regression it
doesn't actually select variables
and set things to zero when as you said
in situations like that previous picture
where things are small would be nice if
they could just say these are zero we
can forget about them so the lasso is a
more recent technique for for shrinking
coefficients in regression it looks very
much like ridge regression but with one
change so here's the
lasso criterion again we have the the
rss
as before
now we have a penalty but whereas before
the penalty was the sum of the squares
of the coefficients now it's the sum of
the absolute values of the coefficients
so it's a shrinkage towards zero using
an absolute value rather than a sum of
squares
and this is called an l1 penalty
uh in by analogy to the l2 penalty the
l1 penalty is just
the sum of the absolute values
it's a norm but it's called the l1 norm
rather than the l2 norm
so what's the effect of changing this
from a square to an absolute value it's
actually a small change but it's quite
important
um
it turns out that
the lasso like the ridge shrinks towards
zero
but it has the effect of actually
setting variables the coefficients of
variables uh
exactly equal to zero when lambda is
large enough
so it's it's neat it does it shrinks but
also it does subset selection in a
similar way to
the best subset selection so it'll set
coefficients to zero exactly if that
feature is not important and lambda is
large enough
so we say that this this there's a term
for this is called sparsity so the last
cell yields was called sparse models
models which only involve a subset of
the variables
and again it's a function of this tuning
parameter lambda which as an original
regression we have to choose somehow
and we'll do so by cross validation
so wow the lasso seems like a really
good idea so clever i wonder who came up
with it rob
thanks
so
daniela's trying to embarrass me so this
was so it's actually a paper that i
wrote in 1996
and it's become
at the time actually it was published
and didn't get a lot of attention but
in the last about 10 years or so it's
become a very hot topic both in
statistics and computer science and
other areas
and there's been a lot of work in
sparsity in general not just regression
but the use of l1 penalties in a lot of
different areas i think one reason for
its popularity now is computation
this computation is actually this is
what's called a convex optimization so
that's good news um
and there's a lot of work in complex
optimization especially in the last 10
or so years and along with so the the
the progress in complex optimization and
fast computation fast computers
um people can solve this problem now of
a lasso for very large values of p and n
and this is actually just been a fun
thing that i've even seen like when i
started grad school you know there was
like one approach that statisticians
were using to to fit this model and um
this was a famous paper that had just
come out when i started and it was
written by
rob and trevor and a few other people at
stanford and statistics and then then a
new paper came out with a better idea
and then 20 more papers came out with
better ideas for how to fit this model
and this has suddenly become something
that anyone can solve on their laptop no
matter how big your data is basically
and so it's just become an incredibly
useful tool in a way that it even wasn't
when i started grad school so we'll talk
about uh glm now which is on our library
which we use a lot in this book and in
the in the book in the course and we'll
we'll show you uh how you can solve a
problem like solve the lasso using glm9r
again where the numbers of variables
might be in the tens of thousands you
can solve it in
on a standard desktop computer in less
than a minute so we'll talk about the
computation later on in the course
but let's let's first see what the what
looks like in the same example now
so again
the credit data set
and we're plotting
the standardized coefficients as a
function of lambda for the lasso again
we haven't talked about how to choose
lambda and that's going to be important
we use cross validation but let's for
now look at the solutions as a function
of lambda for all values of lambda
and now you can see
again when lambda is small
we get essentially the full least
squares estimates when lambda zero we
get exactly least squares if i plotted
this all the way to the left
and now as we increase lambda we get
shrinkage
as we do for ridge regression but
something special happens at this point
for example here
beyond this point all these gray
variables are exactly the coefficients
are exactly zero
whereas for ridge regression they were
small but they weren't zero so it's
actually we can tell it tells us
you can throw away all these variables
at this point and just retain
these three
the blue red and orange
similarly this plot shows you the same
thing in the other direction
so it's it's a combination of both
shrinkage
and selection of variables
and so one thing that's worth mentioning
is that in a lot of applications
selecting variables is actually really
important because you know let's say i'm
working with
a doctor who wants to come up with a
really good way to to test for some
particular disease and he might start
out by getting 30 000 gene expression
measurements for patients with this type
of disease so he starts out with p
equals 30 000 and he wants to find a
really great model that can be used to
transfer this disease
but when push comes to shove and he's
actually going to use this test in the
clinic he doesn't want a test that
involves all 30 000 genes because a test
like that would be too expensive it just
wouldn't be feasible to actually use
but if he can get a test that works
really well that only involves six or
eight or 25 genes that could be a real
breakthrough in testing for this disease
and so just from a practical perspective
the lasso is just hugely useful because
it allows us to efficiently find these
types of sparse models that involve just
a really small subset of the features
you should be you should be my personal
sales salesman
doing good job but but seriously i mean
danielle is right and i i myself i use
the lasso in schools and projects here
at the medical school it's very
satisfying to you know to apply it and
to you know to see it helping helping uh
scientists to find the signal in their
data and come come up with interpretable
subsets among the
thousands of features they present to me
so
at this point it might seem like magic
why it is that that's just using
absolute value penalty gives us the
sparsity property why do we get exactly
zero and i'll i'm going to show you that
in the picture so let's let's think
about that
um first of all
we can we can we we can formulate the
problem in an equivalent way rather than
putting a penalty
remember before i had this i had the rss
plus lambda times the sum of the
absolute values
an equivalent way to say the lasso is to
pose the lasso problem is to say
minimize the rss with a constraint
a budget on the total l1 norm of the
coefficients
okay so this is an equivalent problem in
the sense that if you give me a a budget
s there's a lambda in the previous
formulation that corresponds to the same
problem and vice versa
and by the way if that looks like a
total mystery if you can like reach back
to your you're just in a not so distant
past if you ever took ap calculus and
you saw lagrange multipliers in high
school this is really something that you
you might have truly seen in in high
school calculus a long time ago but for
simpler types of problems and that's
just this is just a more complex
application of that same idea but in a
way that it's bound form is is to me
more intuitive in the lagrange form
because it's think of it this way
suppose you that you you do full least
squares and you get a certain answer and
now i tell you and let's suppose the sum
of the absolute values of your
coefficients is 10.
so you give me an answer and i say well
actually
i want to i want to make your budget
smaller you've spent too much
coefficient so rather than 10 i want to
give you a budget of maybe 5.
so now
i ask you to solve the same problem but
you're not allowed to use the
coefficients
as large as you want you have the total
budget you have is 5 and that's the
bound here so
the last i was giving a budget on the
total l1 norm that you can spend and
within within that budget you have to
fit as well as possible and as a budget
gets smaller and smaller the
coefficients get smaller and smaller if
the budget is zero
the coefficients have to be zero
if the budget is large enough you can
you you're free to use fully squares but
in between the budget's going to trade
off
the size the coefficients would they fit
so i think it's it's quite an intuitive
way of looking at these problems
for ridge regression you get exactly the
same analogy but now the budget is in
terms of the sum of squares so again
this is equivalent to the
the lagrange formulation for ridge
regression we saw earlier
but the reason i want to bring this up
is this following picture which
helps to explain why uh the lasso gives
gives sparsity so on the right is ridge
regression
and on the left is the lasso it gets
this a bit more mathy than most things
in this course but
hang in there and i think if you do
you'll it'll be some payoff so
this picture is ridge regression so
what's going on here this first of all p
is two so there's two coefficients
and i've indicated here the full least
squares estimates so if there's no there
was no penalty i just did least squares
on the two variables i'll call the
solution beta hat and that's this point
and now the sums of squares
in in the in the rss
um the contours of that function and i
was
it's lowest here because that's the
least squares estimate but now as i move
away
if i think of this like as a maybe a
cereal bowl and i slice the cereal bowl
here are the contours so here's the
value at which rss is a bigger value
this next contour is a higher contour of
rss so these are the contours of rss as
i move away from the minimum okay
and
this is the constraint region remember
in ridge regression and this formulation
here says you have a budget
on the total sum of squares of the betas
so the budget is the
the radius of the circle right and here
i have a fixed budget and so
in words
the ridge problem says finally the first
place these contours hit the constraint
region
in other words find me the smallest rss
you can get
within the budget defined by this circle
that's ridge regression and the solution
in this picture is right here
so this is the
the ridge estimates for this budget in
the in the data this particular data
that the data is determining the shape
of these contours and the location of
beta hat
so
ridge regression says finally the first
place the contours hit this constraint
region it's this solution and you can
see because the constraint region the
sum of squares is a circle
this is where the sum of squares of
beta 1 and beta 2
is less than a budget it's a circle
right and unless you're very lucky that
you're not going to hit exactly at a
place where
one or the other is zero
right
now let's move over to the lasso same
picture least squares same thing the the
sum of squares function is the same all
the same up here but this the constraint
region is now the sum of the absolute
values
so rather than a circle it's a diamond
a diamond has corners
so in this picture i've hit this corner
and now i get a place where beta 1 is
beta 1 hat is 0. right so here's the
lasso estimate
so in other words to summarize the
absolute values give you a constraint
region
that has sharp corners and high
dimensions you have
edges and corners
and along an edge or corner if you hit
there you get a zero
so
this is geometrically why you get
sparsity in the lasso
so here's oh sorry um
here's our case first of all the
returned example where we had 50
uh let's see four things for the 45
variables and they all had nonzero
coefficients
so now i'm looking at
comparing
the lasso to ridge
so on the on the left picture for the
lasso we see the
bias variance and mean square error as a
function of lambda
and the right we've superimposed the
biased variance in mean square error of
ridge aggression with the broken line
and the lasso
and we can see that overall
so again the solid line here for mean
square air is the lasso the broken line
is ridge
they're very similar ridges a little
better perhaps right so we don't
we don't do much better we don't do
better at all with the lasso here and
the reason is is that we've got the true
model is not sparse the true model
actually involves
45 variables all of which have been
given nonzero coefficients in the tree
in the population
so so it's not surprising we don't do
better than ridge in this case and one
thing we should mention is the on this
right hand panel the the x-axis is
something we haven't seen before which
is the r squared on the training data
and the reason we have that x axis is
because in this figure on the right hand
side we're plotting both ridge
regression and the lasso so it wouldn't
make sense to to you know show ridge
regression and the lasso with lambda on
the x-axis because the lambda means two
different things for those two models so
when we look at r-squared on the
training data on the x-axis that's kind
of a universally
sensible
thing to measure regardless of what the
type of model is so
um you must have drawn this picture in
the book yeah i made this picture
it's a beauty thank you yeah
okay i would have noticed that detail
otherwise okay so now
now here's a situation where we do we do
perform better with the lasso and this
is the case where
now in the population only two of the
predictors have non-zero coefficients so
the previous situation was
was dense or non-sparse this situation
is sparse
we've only there's only two predictors
in the true model that are nonzero
coefficients
now we can see what happens well
the lasso's mean square error here is
minimized for quite a large value of
lambda
because it wants to make the model
sparse as it needs to there's only two
nonzero coefficients and now when we
compare the lasso to ridge
remember ridge is the broken line
and the lasso is the solid line
you can see we do quite a bit here's the
lasso's mean square error and there's
ridge
is here
you know you can see we're doing quite a
bit better using the lasso in this
situation and again it's not surprising
the true model is sparse
so it pays to use this a a technique
which encourages sparse sparse models
coming out of its its estimation whereas
with ridge it doesn't we don't get a
sparse model we get a dense model
so in conclusion
we're comparing these two techniques
as as is usually the case in in most
things in statistics and science in
general
there's there's no rule that there's no
simple rule that means that you should
always use one technique over another it
depends you always hear that from
statisticians it depends well
it depends on the situation
in in this particular case
if the true model is quite dense most
predictors are not have non-zero
coefficients we expect expect to do
better with ridge if the true model is
quite sparse only a few coefficients
have are non-zero then the lasso can be
expected to do better of course we don't
know that usually we hope actually that
things are sparse because life is
simpler then but going into a data
analysis we have no idea whether the
true number of coefficients non-zero
coefficients is large or small
so we have we
use it's typically to apply both methods
and use cross-validation to determine
the the best model coming out of each
method and then compare the
cross-validated error for the two
methods